i think they are
red
if it turns red it means it's live
but we asked you to turn it back off
again because
to be perfect
so just everybody's aware we're just
holding off colonel jordan who is the
chief of enforcement from fish and game
is on his way over as well as
the
executive director scott mason who is
the administrator in charge of the fish
and game they're both on their way here
we're just delaying the hearing until
they show up
thanks
yes
tommy
first
do you have a question
front
hit the button and it's red you are now
being omitted over the intercom
all right
i'm representative tim lang i am calling
beating to order
i am the chairman of the house fish and
game committee uh as was just explained
to you as you are speaking if you would
please make sure you hit the button so
the red light comes on that will allow
us to make sure that it's being live
streamed on youtube for anybody wants to
listen and they'll be able to hear your
question and hear your speech
so with that i'm going to
introduce up my side of the table so
catherine if you want to start introduce
yourself and
my name is representative catherine a
harvey i'm the ranking democrat on the
fish and game committee thank you
and i am
representative larry laflamme and um
this is my third term my sixth year
on the
fish and game committee
my name's scott mason i'm the executive
director of new hampshire fishing game
my name is dave walsh i'm the assistant
chief of law enforcement for the fish
and game department
thank you guys
so if we can go around and introduce
each each person here and and what your
background is so we have an idea what
who you are and what what you do
right um good morning
yeah um
i am kusi watang from ghana
and i am a fisheries and scientist
um
i work with the ghana national fisherman
council which is the lead stakeholder in
the artisanal industry of ghana
and i also work with the usaid
ghana fisheries recovery activity
project
so i'm
only here to
acquire some experience skills
so which can be used to impact
the artisanal fisheries positively in
ghana thank you
the cote d'ivoire which is in west
africa
i work on
ocean uh topic especially the
marine protected areas
it's a great pleasure to meet you today
and to learn from you
and also to share with you what we know
and what we do well merci thank you
good morning members
thank you very much for hosting us today
and i really think thankful for this uh
presence
so my name is uh shamsuddin abdeleman i
come from comoros comoros is a
small countries between madagascar
and mozambique
and i'm the general manager of the
national fishing company in comoros
top of that i'm working at the
president's office as
advisor for the development of comoros
2030. thank you
hello good morning i'm tommy mello from
cape verde he's an archipelago in west
africa
i am the i am by marine biologist
co-founder and
president of the larger
ngo for marine conservation in the
country
and i am also an entrepreneur in the
sustainable seafood industry thank you
good morning
my name is
ileana silva i'm also from cape verde
i'm a biologist and i work at the
national directorate of fisheries and
aquaculture
which is the identity
responsible for
management and define all the polit
politics uh regarding to fisheries and
aquaculture
so thank you
thank you
my name is
montero
representative of angola
the head of
customs stocks police
thank you
hello everybody
my name is nal
i am the head of policy and partnership
at blue volunteers madagascar
which is an international ngo
i am an
agricultural engineer and i continued in
policy on the science study
my work with the ngo is to to rebuild
tropical fisheries with
coastal communities and i am happy to
participate to this program
to learn from here and also to share
knowledge
with regard to system management of
fisheries sectors thank you
thank you for those introductions um
so
i i think probably um understanding the
differential between the two guys on
this side of the table and the three of
us on this side of the table i'll ask
representative harvey what do you kind
of explain
um
about the laws and how we we bring that
forward and regulations and how we
assign who does what
thank you mr chair the um
here in the state house
our constituents the people who voted
for us will often ask us to bring
a bill forward that they feel is
important for
wildlife management here in the state of
new hampshire
the bill first comes to this committee
which is called the fish and game
committee and we invite people to come
and testify
either for or against that bill
and then we make a decision as to
whether we um
want to go forward with the bill or
rather it should just die right here in
the committee if it goes forward
then it goes to the
everybody that's in the house all 400 of
the people who
were elected to be in the house
we say that it's going to the floor
and again it's debated on the floor and
they make up their mind as to whether
it's a good bill or
a bill that should be
killed right then and there
from there
it is passed over to the other body
which is called the senate
and the senate
hears the same bill in their committee
that corresponds to a fishing game
and
again decides if it should come to the
floor of the senate and if it does come
to the floor of the senate then they
vote so it's a long process of
review which is good because we don't
want to just pass laws willy-nilly we
want to make sure that they really are
the best for our state and so it's a
long process it takes a year
and if it finally passes all of those
steps
then the governor has the final say-so
and he can either sign the bill at which
point it becomes law or he can veto it
so
we
our committee is just the first step of
a long journey for any given bill
thank you
representative laflam once again i just
wanted you to
the new hampshire fish and game
department
rules and regulations and there are
there are applicable laws as well
the executive director
um and the fish and game commission
um are responsible for making various
rules and regulations
but i just wanted to impress upon you
this is every year this this new book
comes out and this is all the new
hampshire laws and rules and regulations
that involve fish and game so it's just
there's a lot more work
involved and um we pretty much pretty
much change something pretty much every
year
and like i say we
the legislature
is responsible for
um fish and game laws
and under those laws um
and i'm trying to segue over to the
executive director
we give
the executive director
the power to make
different rules and regulations um
that may change we only meet every we
have a two-year session
so rules and regulations um
like for example
we don't
tell the fish and game department
how many
of a specific species of fish
someone can possess
the fish and game department and the
executive director takes care of those
various rules and regulations
but
like i say the volume is pretty pretty
extensive
so but i
swing that that way
thank you guys so again just just to
kind of reiterate that the idea behind
is you drove here you saw the lines on
the road so the legislature's job is to
paint the lines on either side of the
road it's the executives rules over here
to stay between those lines and set the
rules so we say that they have the right
to manage
to use the representatives example
fish species and how many you can
possess we don't tell them how much we
just tell them you guys need to regulate
it and then they in speaking with the
biologists um decide
what that looks like um and so i'll turn
over to scott mason who's the executive
director of the fish and game who again
is the
person chiefly responsible for the
regulatory aspect versus the legal
aspect
so
we have basically two bodies of
governing
rules one would be the laws which is
what the legislature passes we call them
rsas in new hampshire
and then the second
are the rules and
in order for me to write a rule
or for well
almost all the rules come come out of
the direct executive director's office
for me to write a rule
i need to have the authority from the
legislature to write a rule on that
particular subject matter
and then we go through a process a
hearing process so that we can get input
from different stakeholders out there so
for example this year
um
one of our commercial
fishermen's it's it's a it's a co-op
down on our seacoast
wanted to institute tuna tournaments
and under new hampshire law we have a
very
expensive permit for an artist for a
person from a different state to land a
tuna in new
hampshire so they've asked for a reduced
rate if that person is involved in their
tuna tournament
it doesn't impact the resource so for us
it doesn't it's not a problem but now
we've got to go through the process
this particular process is probably
going to come back to the legislature
first to authorize a tuna tournament
license or request for a tuna tournament
license and then
we'll go um to the
then we'll go through the rule-making
process
at gelcar which is a com a different
committee at legislature to approve the
process
so the idea comes up
we'll um we'll hold hearings on it
um and then we'll write we'll write the
rules based off of what we're hearing
you know feedback from that
i'm sorry we'll start with a written
suggested rule and then after the after
the hearings we will tweak that rule
before we go through the final process
based off of testimony
and as you can imagine
our role in the law enforcement division
is to enforce the laws and the
administrative rules that are created
in the united states new hampshire and
the united states the first three miles
out in the ocean are state waters so the
state laws in the rules would apply when
you go beyond three miles it's federal
waters
those laws and rules are created by the
national marine fisheries service
however they don't really have much of
an enforcement arm so they deputize us
and we also enforce those laws
so we're authorized to do both
it's probably a little different than
than what you have because each country
probably has their own waters i imagine
so it's a little bit different but the
national marine fisheries service will
will create the laws for all the federal
waters in the united states and then
it's our job to help them enforce that
beyond the three miles
thank you and major you have
so do you have in your department you
have coastal waters enforcement officers
as well as inland enforcement officers
for lakes as compared to the ocean
so good question we have a total of 44
officers we have four assigned to our
seacoast our seacoast new hampshire is
very small it's 18 miles long
so we have four officers but because
especially during seasons when the
commercial fishing is very busy we will
also bring officers from all over the
state they're all required to know the
laws and to be familiar with the coastal
laws so we'll ship them down there for a
day or multiple days to help those four
officers patrol
we have a lot of lobstering going on as
well as commercial fishing so
sometimes we need more offices down
there than what what's assigned to that
area
thank you major
so i guess at this point we'll um
open up for questions and discussion
so
again i tried to give an outline of the
regulatory bodies the legal law bodies
and how they work together
probably most of your questions may be
directed towards the major over there
about uh enforcement
process of what goes on
um so
let's have a conversation
i got
me
thank you nali
um first of all
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for your timing
uh it is really amazing to have find
some time in your agendas to give us
this chance to to make some questions
and so to
to try to make some conversation
um i just want to know that in cape
verde we have a fisher agreement with
europe for example
that we we are facing for the last 15
years
and
to have an idea it's they give us uh one
million dollars for a year
to have license for 35
giant uh fishing vessels so it's nothing
so we have been discussing for example
the cape verde for the third consecutive
year
we have the world record for black
swordfish it animals between ten to
twelve hundred pounds
so uh it and we have the record for the
last three years so imagine if cambered
can just con direct uh some
some
motivation i said to develop this kind
of big game fishing we have 12 vessels
of began fishing just in cape verde if
you want to make an appointment it take
you six months because they are really
completely full of course
so in my view if the governments promote
this kind of fishery that it's more like
sustainable because it's catch release
then i quite believe we will get more
money from this sustainable activity
than to make fisher agreements that is
just depleting our waters in change of
coins okay so for you i re it really
helpful if i can get for your site some
numbers
here in
new hampshire how much money you get it
with the fishing games
because we have here a representative of
the government of cape verde and me and
her we can bring these numbers to cape
verde's desk to show that it's a huge
possibility to have more profitable and
sustainable activity than to keep going
with the fisher agreements for example
with the europe thank you
when you ask about numbers um how much
money the federal government gives us
for enforcement or how much uh is the in
the economy for fishing yes the
profitable yeah
um
i don't have the numbers off the top of
my head but i'd be happy to share what
we do have
um
i think
let me back up just a one step
um
all of our inland water fishing is sport
fishing
we have no commercial fishing on inland
waters in new hampshire
we do have
commercial fishing on our seacoast
uh the number one species dollar wise is
lobster fishing
um we have
over time we we we used to have a lot
more um um
uh
commercial fin fishermen that we don't
have as many as what historically we
used to have so those numbers have have
dwindled um that not so much from uh
well two things number one is from the
changes in regulations that
that have come through for trying to
improve sustainability of the resource
but also just the economics uh impact of
of commercial fishing
um
the sport fishing the the
inland fisheries i believe that's over
uh
180 million a year
is a total um economic impact of new
hampshire's economy
um
on an annual basis we sell about six
million dollars in sport licenses but
that would include people coming to
state um
you know hotels restaurants buying
equipment
paying for guides um in case what you're
talking about you're hiring the boat
that kind of stuff i don't have a number
for a specific number for our sport
marine fishing
um
but going back to that tuna tournament
uh that i was talking about i do know
talking with them they have 70 boats
lined up to compete in that this summer
yeah
so it is a big and that that's kind of i
think would be our equivalent to what
you're talking about would be um sport
fishing for tuna here would be you're
trying to develop a sport fishing for uh
what i apologize was it marlin black
marlin
yeah
okay so i just looked real quick um
on the commercial side of things um new
hampshire's economy they
are the the commercial species the
economic values is about 17 million and
70 percent of that is made up of
lobsters but from the sport fish side i
don't know those numbers so
thank you i think you had a question as
well
yeah thank you i i'm
just not the
question so like a chair of a question
so please right now
okay mercy
thank you okay my questions
so my question is for representative
harvey
consultation
[Music]
so each time you have a hearing with the
public to discuss the bills to to to be
able to discuss the different bills
is it only does it only take place here
or do you go to different towns and
cities throughout the state to hear what
other people have to say
and how do you help the executive
director and the police to fight against
illegal fishing in your area
messy
so yes the uh hearings are all held here
in fact this is the exact room that
they're held in we don't go around the
state
to hear people's opinions
they either come to us
in person
they can email us testimony written
testimony if they can't get here and so
forth but this is where it's held um i
will say during covid
we did have zoom participation but uh
now that covet is on the decline that's
that's not an option they're all in
person
um
as to how we help um
the law enforcement
we we don't really um
we're not really in charge of um
law enforcement ours ours is to pass the
bills that allow the law enforcement to
do what they need to do
so um we don't
take part in the actual law enforcement
in and of itself now
we could if law enforcement felt that
they were not able to do their job
because
of a certain bill
or they needed
a bill clarified or they needed
something else added to our our book
there then they could certainly approach
a representative to introduce that bill
and that would help them it to do their
job but we don't physically go out and
and and do any law enforcement ourselves
i'm sure
as private citizens
if we hear of um
an act that is taking place that goes
against our um rsas
we could report it i personally have
reported um deer that have been poached
um to to fish and game and so forth and
they they have investigated that but but
that's just me doing it personally it's
not me doing it as a member of fish and
game committee or as a legislator i just
knew that something happened in my
community that was wrong
and i took it upon myself to report it
so
so just just so we're clear they're
generally as a state representative or a
state senator
there are two ways a bill generally
comes to us and a bill is just a request
for a change in law it could be because
the law was written 50 years ago and
needs updating
or it could be because um so for various
reasons so generally we have citizens
that'll bring us bills and say hey i
tried to do this and i was told no
and so we research that we decide
whether or not we think that's worthy of
a change in law
and then we'll again submit a bill
uh or request for for a law
and then we hold public hearings on that
the other way and the more common way we
get um bills is from the agency in and
of itself so again the agency recognizes
there's an outdated law or a law that
needs changes in order to help them with
enforcement
and so they'll submit a request to us to
one of the committee members
or any state representative
and say hey this
current law is hindering us from doing
this and if the committee member feels
it's appropriate then we will submit a
bill uh and and and have a public
hearing on that change in law that'll
allow them to further
enforce and there's
three steps basically in our our bill
process the house of representatives
which is the uh the ones they call the
lower house
first has a hearing here and then if we
pass it we decide it's a good idea and
we pass it it goes over to what's called
the senate and the senate will then hear
the bill
if they think it's a good law they'll
pass it
then it goes to the governor of our
state who then will sign it into law
and then we'll allow the
executive branch agency the fish and
game division to be able to act on that
law change the rules and regulations so
just understand there's two there's a
there's a public side or where the
civilians can ask us for law changes and
it's not uncommon for an agent the
agency the enforcement agency to ask us
for a change in law as well
because they can't act and it may be
something about a sp species that's
changed and so therefore we need a law
change it could be uh just again a
modernization of an old law that they're
looking for
further questions we had the opportunity
uh shortly after i came into office
uh to modify a law that was set in 18
was it 97 the bear damage
yeah so we so we actually got to change
a law that was written in the early or
the late 1890s so that been around for a
long time and it it
it
somewhere along the line it was no
longer being enforced the way that it
was written in the law book
so when we took a closer look at it um
they
they put it into a bill and and changed
the law
yes thanks uh folks so
for the question me shushi samsudin and
them uh elena
uh my question is uh
with regard to the
this consultation
who who is involved in this consultation
does it require uh
as it is a law
in link with natural resource management
does it require the involvement of
university or researcher before it is
before it will be presented to our
representative
and once uh accepted
uh
who decided and how
those law will be uh funded
forever for the for their investment on
the ground
yeah thank you
um
we only brought one of our divisions
today which is our law enforcement
division but we do have a marine
biologist a marine division we have an
inland fisheries division with
biologists and we also have a wildlife
division with biologists and then a
subsection of the wildlife division um
it splits into two directions one being
game animals animals we hunt and then
the other one being non-game animals
animals that we don't
you know hunt and eat
um
so we have our internal
biologists within the department
themselves that do research monitor
other research that's going on obviously
you know a research project in vermont
is going to end up with fairly similar
results the one in new hampshire so our
neighboring state
so the research would probably be fairly
similar you know the animals are
traveling back and forth across state
lines all the time
um if you know and the fisheries are
fairly similar um
and then the third structure you talked
about is our university system and we do
quite often
we cooperate with the university on a
research project for example um we're
changing our method of monitoring uh
furbearers
we've always looked at
to try to decide what the current
population of furbearers are we've
always looked at the trapper
effort uh
take
furbearers
yeah
sorry so like mink um muskrats those you
know things that you would you'd turn
into a fox or or whatnot
um
so traditionally what we had done is we
had done surveys surveys of our trappers
taking the hours that they were trapping
versus what their take was to come up
with and use that ratio to to try to
predict what the population of the wild
animal is in the in the field
well recently we've started a program
with the university of new hampshire
where we're doing research on what they
call camera traps using game cameras
and and then
a statistical analysis
of putting these cameras out
as randomly as possible and then coming
back and trying to make predictions off
the population obviously this will take
multiple years to compare you know to
compare numbers back and forth to try to
come up and see if this is a
reasonable way to
predict the the population of the of the
furbearers
in
during the uh sorry just coming so it is
it is more science by science based
decision or economic based decision
um
because
you know like our hunting
um
all of our hunting in all of our inland
fisheries
is is sport based so it's recreational
based
so it's not the economics that that lead
the decision it is the science and the
conservation that leads the decision
um when we get involved and we've
carried that forth into the commercial
um
activities that go on which would be
trapping because trappers are allowed to
sell the furs as well as our
offshore fishing
conservation still leads the decision
there too
um
but obviously
you you you know dealing with the folks
that are involved in this
um
well let me back up for a minute um
give you a little family history my
father was
the second warden
on the seacoast after we shut down
commercial clamming
in new hampshire so back in the 40s
prior prior to i mean i think about 48
is when they shut it down
you had
a lot of people on our seacoast that
supported their family off of digging
clams
and then shucking clams and selling
canned clams all over the world
and that market got shut down and
for
quite a period in the 40s and 50s that
was a very contentious thing you had
these these folks that have been
involved with it for generations
still illegally harvesting clams for
sale so you go down to massachusetts and
and dig clams and sell them uh so it's
it's easy to sell the product um
and it was a long you know it was a long
going fight an ongoing fight that
probably took 10 or 15 years to curb
this um
issue within within that that group of
folks
and obviously
dealing
with the economic impacts of
conservation
you can't ignore that as you're trying
to implement your new policies
and trying to work with these people and
getting past getting past that and
giving them other alternatives for
uh making a living other than
the activity that they used to do is a
very important part of that
and i you know i i don't mean to pick on
my major here but you know some of the
stories my father used to tell
um
they would be involved in fist fights my
father's been threatened with guns my
father's been threatened with knives
over
a bucket of clams
so
what was that been back then
less than a dollar it's worth a claim
so it
but it
because of that history they took it
very seriously
so one of the things i will say
uh relative to this conversation is
around
conservation versus commercialization
and that balance
in the case of laws
we have a when we have a public hearing
for a law
um citizens are more than welcome to
come we have a gentleman from guilford
who's a retired biologist and he attends
on a regular basis and he's he's a
conservationist he very much believes in
conservation of of wildlife
um
and they're all given equal say to have
a conversation we've had to depart
again the university system come in and
speak at a public hearing on a law
change
we have
citizens come in on for various reasons
to come in and speak in favor or opposed
to a law change so it goes through a
very deep vetting process in both the
house and the senate
but even with the agency over here on
the regulatory side when they create
regulations before they can change the
regulation they're required also to have
a public hearing and to have citizens
come in and people who are involved
either the industry
or just a private citizen come in and
speak to them about what the impact of
that regulatory change is going to mean
to them and then it's their job to
balance and weigh that prof uh the the
different versions of what people want
and come out with what's best for new
hampshire again i'll say that they
generally always lean on the
conservation side which is good to
preserve our our uh wildlife and
fisheries management to make sure we
have a sustainable program that'll go
forward and not just deplete it for the
short term money so they've done a great
job at doing that
any further questions or comments or
conversation that's going on sushi
yes um
i am really enjoying the discussions we
haven't
yeah but then my simple question is
um i want to know if the regulators
they do have fisheries background
either maybe master's degree in
fisheries
undergraduate studies or any kind of
you know fisheries program
media background
let me let me come again the background
of the biologist not the background of
the regulators
of the regulators exactly
do they have some kind of history's
background
not necessarily with the law enforcement
no not with law enforcement um we are
required to have either a degree or
experience in law enforcement it's
recommended we have something either
official wildlife but it's not a
mandatory but to be a fisheries
biologist they have to have a master's
degree in fisheries
uh to be a wildlife biologist they have
to have a master's degree in in biology
or wildlife management um let me but
it's not a mandatory for the regulators
right
for enforcement no enforcement and
regulators uh or the legislature
legislature yeah no not really a
mandatory okay and again i want to know
if
what what approach
do you in most cases use
do you use the top bottom approach or
the
um bottom top approach
in trying to execute you know some of
these
your rules
so if i get again
a lot of the times our law and our
regulatory happens because a citizen
bubbled up an issue
right they had a problem they had they
saw something they didn't like
or were involved themselves in something
um so i'll give you an example scott
won't like this one the director but
so this year we had a citizen come
forward with a had a problem with
dealing with the agency and there was no
appeals process for the ruling
of the agency
and so
they brought the bill to me they brought
it to me and so i put a bill in saying
every citizen should have the right to
an appeal and administrative decision if
someone makes a ruling you can't let it
just stop there
so we put a bill together and we should
vote on it and it should become law
hopefully soon
and it was just that it just created
an appeals process from a regulatory
decision and allow that process to occur
because that was what was in the best
interest of the citizen so there was a
case of a bottom-up bubble bubbling up
of of an issue so
good
first thank you
uh so
um
when you talk about the experience level
of
either law enforcement or the
legislators we see bills on all kinds of
different subjects in the house
here in the here in the committee we see
fish and game bills but in the house we
see all kinds of bills so
no we don't have experience
in all of the topics that are brought
forward to us but that's why
the um hearings in the committee room
are so very important and we really
encourage people to come and talk to us
because they're the ones that
do have the experience and so we listen
not just to um citizens we listen to
lobbyists we encourage um you know
people to reach out to us in in any way
rather phone calls or whatever if we're
having a a particularly uh contentious
build one that people feel very strongly
about one way or the other i will get as
many as 300 emails a day
so um
so that's
and and i like that you know i i do
because it it tells me what the people
are thinking
otherwise i would have no idea
so again
my background's in technology i'm an i.t
manager for a living that's what i do
but i'm the chair of the house fish and
game committee um
so
in the case of the other going the other
direction is one of the things we
learned in our in our hunting season for
our recreational hunting um there were
some rules that were just problematic um
i'll use one of i use the pistol is my
favorite one right so we had a rule that
said that
if you were hunting and carrying a
handgun a pistol
for the purposes of self-defense
you could have six rounds of the gun
however
if you were
hunting with a pistol you were only
allowed to have five rounds in the gun
didn't make sense right so so this was
an agency kind of came to us we had a
conversation and we said let's make this
more uniform right and so we we
we set everything at six so it was clean
but for some reason back whenever they
said it that was the way they said it
but we recognized that it created a
problem for our law enforcement officers
enforcing that because how do you tell
whether the gun on a hip is being used
for hunting you're being used for
protection so are you
what do you do with that right so there
was a case where we cleaned law up and
made it more uniform to make it easier
for citizens to follow the law and not
accidentally become criminals
thank you mr chair and the members for
giving us this
time to exchange with you
so
my question will go
i would like to know
a little more about
how
is fishing works in your states uh and
what kind of support you are giving to
the community having said this because
uh
i haven't i have been working with the
fishing communities and through my
companies i have been provided
community buildings and uh
boats and fishing gears and equipments
but at the end uh
uh
50 of 50 percent of them they are not
they are not happy
and uh
sometime
i had the fighting
with them so i would like to understand
how it works
what is the approach with
you you have with your your fishing
communities in order to get
uh
some information to implement to my my
community because i'm working with the
nine communities uh village and uh uh
the total number is 150 fishermen that
i'm working with them
so
the boats the fishing gears the
equipments the committee buildings that
is was free for them so it belongs to
them
from the company but
once they go for fishing the the
condition was that once you come from
there they see 60 of the harvest
has to be
bought by the company for a low price
then the 4.4 40 percent you can either
sell to the company or you can
go to
eat on your home or sell to your your
your communities but they have never
beat
uh or
miss uh
traceability between them uh between
them sometimes they come they say we
don't have we didn't catch anything but
uh back in formation we find that they
got some catch so i had facing all these
issues then
i'm very happy to be
with you and get some advice regarding
this matter thank you
um
we
[Music]
we actually don't get involved in that
part of it as far as the business side
of of the commercial fishing
um
we would be we just enforce the rules
like like on a lobster you know your
lobster has to be
the body of the lobster has to be so
long before you can keep it so we will
go on the boats making sure that the
catch is legal that that kind of
activity
in general
i would dare say that most of our
fishermen are small independent
businessmen themselves they they've
bought the boat themselves
um
the docks tend to be municipal owned
would that be right correct
um so they're owned by the local town
there
sometimes like in seabrook that was a
that dock or that pier
is owned by the town but it's rented to
a local fisherman's co-op so they they
come together as these small independent
businessmen come together into a co-op
and they manage that doc they manage the
facilities there
as things have progressed in the
marketing they've actually developed a
local retail market
so the co-op
supplies the dock
as a member you you kind of pay in and
buy into the ownership of that
but they supply the dock they also
supply marketing for your catch but
you as a member of the co-op you don't
have to sell your catch to them you can
you know i was talking to a gentleman
the other day he loads his catch every
time he comes in he loads it on a truck
and takes it to massachusetts and sells
it down there because he doesn't believe
he can get a good price in new hampshire
so that type of activity happens but
it's a it's a little different as far as
how we manage
um
our interaction with uh with the
fishermen we don't actually manage the
economic side of it
and i would add just add to that the
director talked about how they're
independent businessmen each boat and
if there's a problem with somebody
committing a violation on the commercial
side of things
the other fishermen view that as
they're stealing from them so we're the
last person to find out about it they
kind of take care of things on their own
and when they can't do that that's when
they come to us it is not unusual well
it is unusual but it's not unheard of
for a boat to burn
over the night
and that usually is someone that has
been stealing lobsters or committing
lobster violations
and some fisherman was fed up with it
because he looked at it as they're
taking money out of his pocket so
usually we're the last ones that they
complain to they try to take care of
things on their own because it's they're
losing money as well
so
so i i will also say that there's in the
united states with multiple states that
we have uh on the atlantic seaboard
there is um a group called and scott you
can help me with this it's the uh the
atlantic states marine fisheries
commission which helps set catch limits
if i'm not mistaken for the region so
um we helped report the catch you know
the the cooperatives that they were
talking about private industry reports
back to the in the uh the state and this
helps us maintain sustainability across
the entire eastern seaboard to make sure
that new hampshire isn't you know just
going to be a black hole no fish right
so
again we we participate in regional
cooperatives regional uh commissions
that help set catch limits and then it's
a self-reporting for the for the various
fish cooperatives to report back to
those to that um
regulatory body that'll help maintain so
if we
over catch your lobster we'll use a good
example they may pull back and say okay
once you reach this limit you got to
stop catching
lobster and so they'll help maintain
sustainability in the industry so it's
not burned out
each state has its own quota
so what happens sometimes if it's a fish
that's not
um
something that our fishermen aren't
catching we will trade quotas off with
other states to make sure that that
that we you know our fishermen do get
the the best ability to you know make a
living without harming the resource
so
um
hello
ileana from uh calvert
um
okay
thank you
like tommy said
um
we can promote the fishing games back
home and i truly believe that
we have all the condition conditions to
to do that so
uh i want to to know um
how do you start the big games here in
new hampshire and what were the the
steps
you you you took to be where you are now
thank you
can you repeat the beginning of that
question i apologize i'm a little hard
of hearing too so
now i said that uh
back in home in cabo verde we can
promote fishing games uh fishing games
and uh i think we have all the condition
conditions to do that
so my question is uh to know how do you
start the fishing games here
uh what are you talking about games
fishing games games
yeah okay now i i
how do we get people to do sport hunting
and fishing instead of commercial
hunting and fishing yes okay thank you
well um
our history
fishing game is we just celebrated 150
years in new hampshire so we our agency
started over 150 years ago
um
what happened was is our
uh resources you know
um
our rivers used to run black with salmon
for example you know coming you know
coming up the rivers to spawn
and they were commercially harvested to
the point where we've lost that resource
as well as impacts to the habitat you
know dams were built on these rivers
um environmental impacts pollution to
the rivers and whatnot like that so we
lost our resources
um
on like fisheries uh hunting you know
the um
partially do a combination of over
hunting because you used to have market
hunting we used to be able to go shoot
ducks and sell ducks that you shot uh
our
forest industry in the old days you
would
have men go back into the woods and live
at
you know lumber camp and they would live
up there all winter the trees were cut
in the winter they were um you know sent
to the rivers and swished down you know
the sawmills further further
um
and those camps were fed with venison
fed with moose
and and some of those species
we had some issues with
so by the time we got involved it was
actually to save some of these species
there were very few deer left in the
state of new hampshire when fish and
game became involved in it
um
so
that was one of our early you know early
steps where to shut down commercial
the sale of wildlife other than as they
say fur bears and and and some of the
commercial
uh salt water fishing
um
i would dare say we probably waited too
long
and and
it's a combination of hunting pressure
fishing pressure as well as habitat
pressure environmental pressure on the
habitat and and we waited too long to to
make some changes it took a long time um
new hampshire you look around today and
you see trees everywhere well if you
were here in the 1820s you wouldn't see
hardly a tree
this was you know we used to grow all of
our own food here and then as the west
opened up you know people moved out west
so those farms you know some of the
farms were kept in production um sheep
we had the amisk woolen mills excuse me
down in manchester those are the largest
at the time they were the largest woolen
mills in the world
so when you looked around new hampshire
you used to see nothing but sheep they
were everywhere
and as time went on these markets
changed and that land
stopped being farmed and started growing
back up and that's
that was partially what happened to
return some of our wildlife species that
we that had been here back in the 1700s
or the 1600s when folks first got here
um and that's been you know that plus
the work we do i think is has led to a
you know a major change in in what what
we now see
um
i you know i grew up
probably about 10 miles from here as a
kid
we never saw a black bear in town oh you
know my whole you know until i was in
college never never saw a black bear in
town
uh now it's pretty regularly that they
see black bears down here
um same with moose we didn't use to see
moose in southern new hampshire now
well now it's starting to go the other
way but uh you know now we have moose
spread out across the state
as far as
how to make those changes i i go back to
my father's stories that he told me when
i was a child
i think part of it is you've got to give
these folks an opportunity to do
something else
um you know another economic pathway to
their own personal success because at
the end of the day they're they're just
trying to feed their family and and
they're doing it through harvesting wild
game
um so giving them opportunities in life
becomes a crucial part of being
successful
being fair with these folks
i think sometimes
and
we concentrate on the goal
and we can sometimes forget the impact
that that goal has on people and i think
you know you need to be fair with with
folks
honest you need to bring them into the
solution
give them a voice in how the solution
will impact them
right now we're going through some major
changes on the seacoast with our lobster
industry we're trying to protect
whales
right whales seem to have a hard time on
navigating around
lines in the water so as i assume
lobster traps are sitting on the bottom
of the ocean and they're you know we
have like 10 or 20 of them tied together
and then you have a line going up to a
buoy on top at the surface and sometimes
if a whale swims by they can get tangled
in these lines and with the
the
the way the right whale
responds when he comes in contact with
one of these lines makes them much more
susceptible to getting entangled and and
being hurt
and they are an endangered species so
we're we're right now going through a
process of having breakaway lines so
that there's a weak link in that line so
if a whale gets tangled in the line um
it'll break away and hopefully save the
whale so these are new regulations
um
our lobstermen are concerned about the
cost they're concerned about you know
having to recover traps after the line
gets broken
um
a bunch of issues but as i say working
with the lobstermen and trying to get
buy-in becomes a very a very important
part of that
does that answer your question
and then the other part of it is i think
in your case
let us go back to new hampshire at the
turn of the century in you know the
1890s 1880s
um you know
is getting tourists to come and hunt and
fish and pay for those licenses and and
pay
into the economy to create jobs for some
of those folks so
um
i come i live now i live at the northern
end of the state and
that's kind of where a lot of our
our guides work out of so we have quite
an economy
up there uh during hunting season where
people come and stay
you have restaurants you have hotels you
have guides that all make a living off
of um we use the word sport but you know
a tourist
hunter or angler that comes up that
wants to experience this
one of the things
we've seen that um you know i i grew up
poor i grew up you know not a lot of
money so it never really i didn't
understand it until i had an opportunity
to work with one of our fortune 500
corporations here in the united states
and you know you get these um um
executives from these large companies
and
they want to experience
catching the big fish or or catching the
big deer or or whatever
and they have very limited time to do it
which means they're willing to spend a
lot of money for the right people to get
them to where they want to go
and
in our case here we deal with tourism
from outside of new hampshire
on your case you may need to deal with
tourists outside of your country trying
to attract folks into the country to to
come and fish that kind of stuff
is that
so one of the last i'll say just to tack
on to that for the executive jacket one
of the big things the agency does is
education
working with
all the different partners whether it's
the general public for the sport fishing
the inland fishing and working with them
they provide
hunter safety and hunter education
courses
they work with the as you just heard
with the fisheries dealing with the
breakaway lines for them right
so again it's the cooperative effort
between the agency not using a hammer to
force stuff
but
doing the soft cell and working with it
to find a common ground that that works
together
on a regular basis for the sports
fishing in new hampshire we have like
open days for fishing where you don't
have to own a license you can just go
and fish so to try to get people
interested in doing inland sports
fishing
without a cost right they can just go
out on a saturday afternoon and go
fishing no don't not have a license and
if they enjoy it then they'll go buy a
license and they'll do it again which
helps promote the system helps promote
the guides that the executive director
was talking about that's a big piece in
new hampshire uh because again we don't
have commercial hunting you know for the
most part we have corbyn park but i
think other than that we have generally
limited uh commercial hunting and we
don't have any inland commercial fishing
except for with guides and so that's a
big aspect of what what the executive
director was talking about so promoting
those
tourism activities promoting those
recreational activities help sustain
they have a pretty large um hatchery
program to stock our inland fisheries to
stock our lakes and to stock our streams
with fish so that whenever you go out to
do recreational fishing there's actually
a fish for you to catch
to keep that to keep that happening so
again i think education
and sustainability programs that the
agency's done has been phenomenal and
helped new hampshire in keeping the our
program i scott if i'm not mistaken last
year was the largest year in record for
revenues for the fish and game
department
um
yep so again last year due to the advent
of covet everybody wanted to be outside
nobody wanted to be inside but fish and
game was able to capitalize on that and
we sold more fishing license we sold
more hunting licenses things outdoor
activities were highly promoted um
because nobody wanted to be inside so it
rate increased the revenue for the
agency that agency is one of the few
agencies in our state that's
self-funding so all the revenue they
make they keep and they use for their
own agency um
and so uh it's it's when we have places
like this where we can increase revenue
and be self-sustaining it helps a on the
tax rate for our local citizens and and
helps get people more people involved in
in outdoor activities
yeah
thank you a lot we are running out of
time so maybe last question from montero
and
then if you have some questions to us
and thanks
montero
yes thank you
well um i would like to know
if it's possible
to have depend on legislation
in
force the penalties
legislation
yeah that that
yeah
yes but i i i know i know that uh you
have um uh different and several
legislations i would like to have only
the panel legislation
that we can find translations that we
can find the crisis
if it's possible
i think the two things you're looking
for you're looking for some of the state
regulatory aspect from the agency itself
as well as maybe we can see about
getting you guys copies of our state
laws i'll see if i can get those two
things put together and sent to you guys
so the major major will help us get the
information i'll give it to a niece and
she can get it out to you guys okay okay
okay because uh
in angola i'm from angola yes because in
angola
our legislations um
some conducts we consider that is crime
and another another conduct we consider
that is transgressions
you know transgression
on which we apply
fines
and on crime is that
we can arrest
arrest the proprietors
and in the codes
judges
in occurrence of the law
yes
and i would like to study it you have to
make a difference to compare
our legislation and your congratulations
most of ours are violations which is a
fine um
some of the more serious ones are
misdemeanors and there's very few
felonies
but i think
uh
and i'm speculating here in angola if if
if you have a large game species that's
endangered that's probably a very
serious offense we don't have a um well
nobody can hunt or take an endangered
species and we don't have a lot
so
most of our violations occur with game
species so you may be able to shoot a
deer but you can't do it in may and that
would be you know a misdemeanor which
they could arrest but uh we don't
typically see the very large fines and
the very large penalties unless it's a
repeat offender over and over again um
so there are a lot of differences but um
i could try to get get you some
information on that
probably the most serious
infraction or i won't say infraction but
penalty is taking away the license for a
period of time so a lot of times you
will re if it's a multiple offender or a
serious offense
will take away a person's right to have
a hunting license or a phishing license
for a period of time a year five years
to say you know we've given you three
chances and you keep doing the same
violation so now
it's just illegal you can't have a
license ever or for a period of time i
should say
and that's one of the most the biggest
deterrents with all the fish and game is
if you lose your ability to do it and
with the commercial phishing side
if you have so many violations and you
lose your commercial license you lose
your livelihood so it's something they
pay attention to
okay uh thank you sir uh
it's finished uh
can we have time it's done it's done
yeah
we are running out of time so
if you have maybe something one is one
question or a general uh comment for for
us it's nice and then we can take a
picture
i i just wanted to thank you all for
coming and and and participating i think
it was a good exchange of information um
and and i thank the commissioner and the
branch and my fellow representatives i
did want to apologize for the senate the
chairman of the senate uh did reach out
to me and they were unable to attend to
a conflict
but um we're very happy to have you guys
here um anis will provide you my contact
information as well as everyone who sat
here today so if you have any future
questions when you get back home and
you're like oh what did he say or what
you know what are we doing here feel
free to reach out to any one of us we'll
be happy to respond it's the one thing
about new hampshire is you can get right
to the executive director of fish and
game for the entire state and he he does
answer his emails or at least mine
but um but i want to thank you and and
um again i have
uh the sheet with your contact
information on it and i'll make sure if
we have anything we have questions on
we'll reach out to you guys
so thank you
yes go ahead
yeah yes that is an important uh moment
also
and with that the hearing is closed
you